there is a supposed increase of cheaters
in valorant and for a game known for its
robust anti-cheat that is a pretty
damning accusation so let's get right
down to it does Riot have a cheating
problem on their hands
[Music]
there are a few certainties in life
death taxes and an invasive anti-cheat
that works pretty well from Riot games
named Vanguard in fact Wright is so
confident in their anti-cheat they
released a video talking about how they
deal with cheaters saying that cheating
is an anomaly understand that we are
detecting identifying and removing
cheated at a rate faster than ever
before the average shooter in valorin
doesn't even make it 12 hours before
getting banned she developers have given
up trying to make undetectable solution
it's a when not if that a cheat will be
detected and banned by Vanguard it's a
war of attrition against cheat
developers who are always trying to sell
their product to the next soccer as
someone who has seen only one cheater
detected screen in her entire career
playing ballerant I am inclined to
believe it besides that I have rarely
encountered someone in a game where I'm
like huh they're cheating because of how
robust Vanguard is but recently online
discussion has begun to surface saying
that cheating is a problem in valorant
this is a Reddit post called cheating
increase part two that includes cheating
is so common in valorant now I almost
mistake this game as 2018 CS go 2018 CS
go is a wild accusation to make because
if you know you know but looking through
the reply is people were agreeing saying
that this really is becoming an issue
now if you're like me your first thought
is this doesn't make any sense after all
this is the game that made headlines
with Vanguard their kernel level antichi
the thing about Vanguard is that it also
not only is just about detecting active
cheaters there are a lot of preventative
measures to prevent somebody from
cheating at all in the first place
connecting the game's memory from access
by most cheats it just makes cheating in
Valor a lot harder with such a robust
anti-cheat ballerin has had very few to
cheaters I'm confident in saying that
the consensus of the community is that
there were very few cheaters nor was it
even a hot button topic of conversation
also I'm on Twitter I know about the
anti-cheat PD who literally has
thousands of followers because of the
work that they do with plans to expand
and their words we specialize in
gathering Intelligence on cheats to
detect and disrupt cheating vendors one
of their Chi analysts laser told me that
they don't only cover what we would
think about as typical cheating like
Aimbot but also cover five stock abuse
when trading ELO boosting and toxicity
but we are talking about those typical
hacks like aimbots walls Etc
unfortunately many hackers aren't
willing to talk and divulge all of their
Trade Secrets and I'm not willing to
download cheat software for hopefully a
very obvious reason that being said
however I decided to look around and it
seems like to me that cheats were
alarmingly easy to find but I was told
that these cheats are largely scams and
detectable a lot of these cheats just
end up it's called exit scamming
basically they do you have Lego cheat
that does work for a little bit and then
the moment they get detected they just
pull the rug they usually make a bunch
of money off of it by selling like
extremely long subscription times for
like a discount you know um and then way
before the time is up they just leave
but that didn't answer the question of
is cheating a growing problem so I
straight up asked month over month we're
getting a 25 increase in reports but the
number of cheaters that are punished
every month have actually stayed
about the same there's there is no
increase in cheaters
um now that we're processing other types
of malicious play there's like a
significant increase in reports overall
but the numbers are still as expected
statistically speaking there just are
not more cheated than they were in the
past
um social media has drastically
increased a perceived number of cheaters
but you know cheating in Ballard is like
more difficult and expensive than it's
ever been as the days go by more and
more cheats are getting detected and
patched out when I asked why some people
were reporting an increase of cheaters
Rye game's very own Matt pilate
anti-cheat manager for ballerin said to
me that cheaters have caught on to the
attention they received from the
promotion of their activities and are
using cheating more as a platform for
attention rather than Glory some
cheating groups in specific regions have
also made efforts to continually attempt
to cheat and display their actions to
try to demoralize others and influence
them into obtaining their product they
are highly opportunistic even trying to
time their play around times when they
think we may not be able to respond as
quickly we continually look at various
factors such as reports social media
feedback and most importantly on the
ground Chi intelligence to identify
threats from all cheat types and all
regions and aim to tackle these
orchestrated attacks a recurring thing I
saw in my research was the examples of
tick tock live streams with cheats being
used and links to cheats laser however
was quick to point out that quite simply
it's there are a lot of tick
tock live streams where people kind of
just stream their cheats and be like wow
you could buy my cheat and you'll be
really good at the game
um and just like right said we just like
to say that one there are either scams
to replaying old footage or three
already detected cheats like oh it's
basically out there just to make it seem
like you can just racetrack for hours
and hours and you'll never get banned in
it's just completely true but what about
the community that has to deal with
these cheaters I asked on Twitter and
vlr not rslash ballerin since I deleted
my post thank you very much and to ask
them about is cheating and growing
problem and what do they think Twitter
was mostly no with few and far between
yeses Twitter also reminded us that
Rainbow Six Siege has had it much much
worse for much longer vlr was also
resounding no with some few and far
between yeses something I noticed a lot
of people were saying is that they ran
into very few cheaters in their entire
time playing balance but when they did
their match ended up being terminated
and that gut feeling may be right Matt
Pilates said to me that quote about five
percent of ranked games have a player
reported more than once for cheating
whereas one percent of ranked games have
a cheater in them and remember a lot of
Valor players are coming from different
games like Siege where cheating was such
a big issue that it was literally a meme
or just a constant topic of conversation
it's like asking an Oscar winner to
perform good night Moon it is a joke to
them and what they've experienced so
what does all of this tell us well if we
believe the people I spoke to Riot and
my pole cheating is not a growing issue
and Vanguard is working just fine there
is however a growing conversation around
it most likely due to Greater awareness
of cheating when you see a cheater sure
they could be cheating but remember that
is strictly from your point of view
especially since we don't have a replay
system we all have experiences and
biases that color our conclusions so my
advice in your next balance match when
someone hits an impossible shot or
clears something they shouldn't have
maybe give them some credit before
crying cheats because maybe you haven't
gotten rid of those bad habits since
beta and no one in your stack has told
you because they probably still have
them too we often get reports of uh from
streamers who are like oh they just know
where to go uh like every time they're
always at the right site other they have
like five stacking at every site that's
just not how cheats work in Valor you
know it's either like stream swiping or
they're really just getting lucky and
then some people just can't accept that
and cheaters hi allow me to repeat
something that both Riot and Laser said
if you'll be caught it is a matter of
when
and don't forget to pray for me because
I'm calling the damn show and I'm going
to need all the help I can get so
calling a show uh for those who you
don't know basically just means I make
everything on stage that isn't the actor
move the lights the sets the curtain
like all of that I like tell people to
do that the opening of the show is going
to turn my hair gray I'm going to
hmm
I'm good I'm fine